[Music]
instructing off news always sorry of my
life I used can you're a mother all
right these are the two hardest workers
in this [ __ ] room you understand that
damn
David changed I just saw my mom recently
that's why some on this like [ __ ] you
know I mean around the world
mom's submitted by May is a sniper
excuse me
I read that's a man that's good she's
gonna good a California DMV worker slept
on the job three hours a day for about
four years and still works better oh
that just shows how shitty the DMV is
dude I feel like once you get hooked up
with a government job and then you kind
of stay after this pert what do you call
it like a tender like 10 euro you know
whatever it's hard as [ __ ] to get fired
to mess sleeping on the job feels so
much better than sleeping at home I know
why is sleeping at school at school
feels it feel so much more restful
nothing puts me to sleep like a lecture
like a college lecture yeah cuz when I'm
at home and I supposed to sleep I can't
sleep we're not sleeping I supposed to
do an important [ __ ]
yeah responsibility bro have you ever
slept on boxes though because you're
working in the world yes yeah it's it's
one of the most common and in the
warehouse is all nice and cool you [ __ ]
and then you just [ __ ] crunch on the
boxes and you just know what that feels
like I slept all boxes before ready man
nice
y'all have a sleep on box lost gotcha
yeah
god the sound of that day on my back
when I get up consciously he wants to be
homeless so bad he's gone through years
of training how you do it's actually
please Papa I just wake up with a tin
can with the lid open when I need some
beans I just shake it a little bit yeah
so there was an audit recently and they
found that this DMV employees slept
three hours a day on the drop for nearly
four years while of the supervisors knew
about it oh she didn't have like low
blood pressure and like like they needed
it somehow she did have a doctor
indicating that she could perform all
her duties she requested a wreath for
reasonable accommodation but it was
denied you know I don't mind this if she
like let's say she has eight hours of
work right I don't mind it if she took
that three hour break but then she's
still finished her eight hours you were
gonna say [ __ ] I was but I know she so
what actually is it a she it's a person
I always picture a DMV worker as a she
though and specifically the one in
content a very sassy and happy lady with
long nails
they always got long nails and I [ __ ]
love another hella nice so she works as
a data operator which is like the people
that enter [ __ ] in they interested I
haven't gone to the DMV in ages I just
want recently she's a disaster it's a
[ __ ] disaster
really I've gotten a lot better I've
been a little bit nicer but it's still a
[ __ ] yeah that's why I still have a
license plate so I'm trying to pick up
my custom license plate we have to wait
in that [ __ ] line yeah I don't like
three hours like an appointment for the
DMV I got there and I finally got to the
person three hours later even with the
appointment yeah that's how it works you
need to make an appointment but you
still have your data
lucky recently because as soon as they
show up like I get well what did you
flash your titties or what happened no
go on the weekday yeah that's what yeah
sometimes you get sometimes you're lucky
I got triple-a just so I can do [ __ ]
tree and be kind of [ __ ] just yeah third
your boy but there's like one thing that
you have to do at the DMV and I think
it's like a renewal your license renewal
yeah so an average data operator they do
about 560 documents a day but this lady
only did about 200 in which everyone
that she actually did do terrible they
were terrible they had a lot of mistakes
all the other data operators had to pick
up the slack oh my god there were so
many complaints about this lady the
supervisors thought that she was only
sleeping for 30 minutes so they thought
like I no big deal okay Big Apple asleep
into like watched her for 30 minutes is
like okay that's it so then the reason
no unless she's like hot too so he was
just like I'm just let everything slide
I wonder if like we can get a
reinvestigation on why the [ __ ]
government ranch [ __ ] is so bad that's
everyone's comfortable like you have all
that security and [ __ ] and it's like
it's it can be a fire fire somebody
that's doing shitty work then yeah
they're like then yeah you're gonna do
the bare minimum yeah I mean get the
public [ __ ] tell on them or like you
know and there's gotta be some kind of
checks and balances it's like well this
lady got away with it for so long she's
still working there still working there
too punk-ass [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] up and the supervisors are
still working there too cuz they're
saying that they could have performed
disciplinary actions against her because
the law or the girlfriend's no because
they're saying that so the Human
Resources have said that there was not
appropriate language necessary for
disciplinary action so she's getting
away with like a loophole cuz I guess
like whenever they would write [ __ ] down
against her like complaints no they
didn't use appropriate language so they
couldn't discipline her what's
appropriate like they they wrote this
[ __ ] [ __ ] all day this ball game let
me tell you about this that's [ __ ]
did I tell you which DMV this is no I
wanted to know
I feel like if you just say California I
play those one at every single one of
them was like this I feel like the DMV
annoys everyone that if then if an ex
campaigning president comes out and says
I guarantee that if you make me
president all the [ __ ] DMVs will be
efficient
they'll be dope I bet you don't win
that's the only thing that they gotta do
feel like they do it like they [ __ ]
everything up intentionally the DMV yeah
let me [ __ ] your life up there was a
long time ago I had to fix some [ __ ]
about my registration and then for some
reason I couldn't do it in person like I
went in I'm like I'm trying to fix this
they're like no you need to call his
phone number call that phone number and
then they kept telling me like whenever
it was only like voice whatever I
couldn't punch in numbers or anything
and every time I said something it would
read it as something else
and I'm like jaws when you had your
accident and still what it work and I'll
just like what the [ __ ] is all this
say bye-bye bye
no I would have none see it as that's
the thing just say yes sir yes yes then
I just could never get anywhere and I
think I spent like three hours on hold
once and then they hung up on me and I'm
just like [ __ ] you please you're just
trying to make my life I'm just I can't
I can't hate on a DMV too bad because
when I uh when I got a new license right
I didn't I thought it was just one of
those where you go in and you sign up
you take another picture but you have to
actually take the test again really it
depends it was that time frame because I
think yeah yeah it's long enough every
five or ten years you got to do it right
yet so I showed up and I was like oh
[ __ ] good even prep so I did the tests
all super nervous and I [ __ ] up the
first one Oh No then the second one
they're like you get another chance the
second when I was off by one point and
it was a sweet little Armenian lady she
goes okay for you I do for you no no I
was like oh my god thinking I started
saying thank you and [ __ ] like that
shows though I didn't do anything
I was like oh hell yeah so if you're
gonna [ __ ] cut corners like that DMV
I love you yeah so those ladies
so she slacked off between February 2014
and December 2017 she apparently wasted
about 2200 hours worth of work
costing California taxpayers more than
$40,000 one in person oh my god happened
so much though is she still working some
people though they bit baby to
definitely review like Road rules cuz a
lot of people don't know road rules and
they get mad at other people when
they're [ __ ] up oh yeah I get a little
Tokyo there's just a garage that I
always leave and there's a double solid
double yellow you're not supposed to
cross it so you go around and you're
supposed to go the other way
this [ __ ] [ __ ] would if the
whole line was backed up out the parking
rush cuz he would not he wanted to go
the other way and you know it's when
you're talking about yeah you would not
go the other way and so I start a hug
actually got out my car I went
Dabo [ __ ] yellow that's all I said
and they're like well I'm trying to go
this way it's a double [ __ ] yellow
just win that let me span off the other
way I like [ __ ] are you doing man
you've been hot in LA so my [ __ ]
tempers like this big right now yeah and
you get other people honking at me like
I'm not going oh [ __ ] neither one you're
the person right behind them right
behind the honking me sometimes I just
want to take out binoculars like look
you see what's happening on the front
[ __ ] use your eyes bro I'm lucky that
person was small in that car that guy
was like your size I want a [ __ ] went
right back in my car got my secret of my
own ass you know what you say I'm saying
get your fat ass back in the car bro
immediately did lucky that person was
tiny bug [ __ ] I haven't had that that
bad of an experience at it's like secret
times that you gotta go like Tuesdays at
3:00 or something they even pose like
the wait time like how long it takes it
does not mean [ __ ] online
yeah limes you can look at it I was
three hours my wait time was supposed to
be twenty minutes at most and she was
like oh this is real fast you'll get in
quick
three [ __ ] hours man g9 don't make any
sense yeah they're like random what the
[ __ ] j5 they have a kiosk that you can
just go up to and you don't even have to
see any what do you to get your
registration I think you like certain
things so what do rich people and
celebrities do Wow you sign up what is
that power of attorney I get a system to
do this [ __ ] yep that's all time look
into it are you guys gonna do that trust
people people be trifling because you
got to give them a helicopter [ __ ]
Social Security Alaska that means you
need a [ __ ] time bomb in their heart
so when they [ __ ] up
[Music]